do you think there's an objective
function that describes the entirety of
uh
human life
so
you know usually the way you ask that is
what is the meaning of life
is there
a universal objective functions that
captures the why of life
so yeah i mean i suspect that they will
ask this question but it's also a
question that i asked myself many many
times
see i can tell you a framework that i
have these days to think about this
question so i think that fundamentally
meaning of life has to do with some of
our reward actions that we have in brain
and they might have to do with
let's say for instance curiosity
or human connection which might mean
understanding others
it's also possible for a person to
slightly modify their reward function
usually
they mostly stay fixed but it's possible
to modify reward function and you can
pretty much choose so in some sense
reward functions optimizing reward
functions they will give you life
satisfaction
is there some randomness in the function
i think when you are born there is some
randomness like you can see that some
people for instance they
they care more about building stuff some
people care more about caring for others
some people
that there are all sorts of uh default
reward functions and then in some sense
you can ask yourself what's this like
what is the satisfying way for you to go
after this reward function and you just
go after this reward function and you
know some people ask
are these reward functions real
i almost think about it as
let's say
if you would have to discover
mathematics
in mathematics you are likely to run
into various objects like a complex
numbers
or differentiation some other objects
and these are very natural objects that
arise and similarly the reward functions
that we are having in our brain they are
somewhat very natural that you know
there is a reward function for
for understanding
like a comprehension yeah
curiosity and so on so in some sense
they are in the same way natural as
their natural objects in mathematics
interesting so you know there's the uh
the old sort of debate is mathematics
invented or discovered you're saying
reward functions are discovered so
nature
nature provided some you can still let's
say expanded throughout the life some of
the reward functions they might be
futile like for instance there might be
a reward function maximize amount of
wealth
yeah and this is more like a
learning reward function
and but we know also that some reward
functions if you optimize them you won't
be
quite
satisfied well i don't know which part
of your reward function resulted in you
coming today but i am deeply
appreciative that you did spend your
valuable time with me well check is is
really fun talking to you you're you're
brilliant you're a good human being and
it's an honor to meet you in an honor to
talk to you thanks for talking today
brother
thank you lex a lot i appreciated your
questions curiosity i had a lot of time
being here
you